madame monsieur bonjour bienvenue à
auxerre en direct sur france 3 bourgogne
pour un nouveau débat consacré aux
municipales à huit jours du premier tour
alors malheureusement ici le soleil
d'hier a laissé place à un ciel bien
gris mais nous avons malgré tout choisi
de nous installer en plein coeur du
centre-ville à quelques pas de la tour
de l'horloge et face à l'hôtel de ville
c'est là que je vous propose de
retrouver nos invités
nous sommes ensemble jusqu'à 12h20 pour
cette émission réalisée en partenariat
avec france bleu auxerre et bien sûr
pour débattre des grands enjeux de ces
élections à auxerre une ville longtemps
géré par jean pierre soisson et qui est
encore omniprésent ici et qui a basculé
à gauche en 2001 à l'image de paris lyon
ou encore dijon et depuis c'est vous qui
ferrait ce qui en est le maire bonjour
vous présenter pour un troisième mandat
en tête d'une liste ps europe ecologie
les verts modem que vous avez vous lu
ouverte et intitulé ensemble l'avenir en
confiance face à vous guillaume larrivé
bonjour vous mener une liste ump udf
également ouverte à d'autres composantes
et dont le slogan contient peu les mêmes
termes ensemble construisons l'avenir
alain rémond bonjour vous êtes à la tis
à la tête d'une liste du front de gauche
qui comme dans toutes les villes est
intitulé pour l'humain d'abord et enfin
julien guibert bonjour vous mener la
liste du front national
auxerre bleu marine et puis n'oubliez
pas vous à la maison comme chaque samedi
vous pouvez réagir posez vos questions
via notre site internet sur facebook ou
sur twitter hashtag lvl bourgogne alors
avant toute chose messieurs j'aimerais
me connaître votre vision de cette ville
comment voulez définissez vous cette
ville d'auxerre la commencer par par le
maire sortant côté j'ai envie de vous
dire concert est une ville d' équilibre
sans cette réforme du ter nous sommes ce
matin au coeur d'auxerre au coeur de ce
qui se fait d'histoire d'auxerre son
patrimoine une ville qui est resté à
l'écart des vicissitudes de l'histoire
et dont le patrimoine constitue
incontestablement un atout un atout de
qualité de vie un atout si dans le cas
de l'économie touristique or donc a
passé très riche j'aime rappeler qu
auxerre et était au 2e siècle la
capitale spirituelle intellectuelle et
religieuse de l'europe occidentale mais
en même temps si tu une ville qui c'est
épouser son temps et l'évolution de son
temps et au moment où nous nous trouvons
dans ce magnifique coeur de ville se
déploie sur la ville la fibre optique
est donc auxerre a le pied dans le passé
qu'il assure et a également un pied dans
l'avenir reste auxerre est-ce de la
capitale du département sur l'ensemble
des plans voilà comment je vois auxerre
et voilà comment je vois auxerre
aujourd'hui et comment je continue de
l'avoir pour demain guillaume larrivé
vous êtes le député de la
circonscription que représente cette
ville d'auxerre pour vous comme député
dossards et aussi tout simplement comme
un auxerrois parmi les auxerrois je
porte à la fois un regard amoureux
dosser est un regard lucide sur ce
qu'est notre vie nous avons des atouts
formidables notre patrimoine notre
histoire notre identité de cité
bourguignonne ancrée dans un territoire
formidable nos vieilles pierres nos vins
notre gastronomie mais en même temps
nous avons des faiblesses des faiblesses
qu'il faut regarder en face si nous
voulons les surmonter la diminution de
la démographie l'appauvrissement de la
population le recul de l'industrie ce
sont des faiblesses qu'ensemble nous
devons surmonter pour préparer l'avenir
à la réponse précise que vous êtes aussi
conseiller municipal sortant vous quelle
est votre vision de cette ville de votre
ville bien effectivement si auxerre a
connu des grandes heures de gloire dans
le passé à mon avis elle a raté quelques
rendez-vous dans les années 60 70
aujourd'hui mon inquiétude c'est ça
reste une ville agréable à vivre une
ville avec un patrimoine riche
effectivement mais le problème et les
derniers chiffres que nous ont
communiqué la préfecture m'inquiète
terriblement puisqu'au 1er janvier 2014
auxerre n'a plus que 35 1545 habitants
document de la préfecture qui nous ont
été communiqués pas longtemps donc nord
35 milles ce sont les documents de la
préfecture et 1522 puisque vous
engueuler les faits monsieur ferrasse en
anglais mais moi le toc mais conteste de
la préfecture que j'aide en rectifiant
suffit d'aller consulter le site de
honorent leurs âmes se rendent à 8 37 me
contant la population que le préfet dit
n'importe quoi dans les documents qu'ils
nous distribuent quand on va chercher
les documents administratifs pour faire
des listes on y reviendra on réglera ça
avec le préfet donc une ville qui a
perdu en termes d'industrie
effectivement ces dernières années on
peut pas nier donc une ville qui doit
rebondir aujourd'hui
les moyens de rebondir pour redevenir
effectivement une ville autour de 40 42
43 mille habitants dans les dix ans qui
viennent il ya beaucoup de travail à
faire julien me guilbert votre vision de
la ville d'auxerre eh bien écoutez nous
sommes inquiets pour l'avenir auxerre la
belle endormie n'a jamais aussi bien
porté son nom tout est en baisse
l'emploi la sécurité la qualité de vie
mais tout n'est pas qu en baisse il ya
des hausses une hausse de la fiscalité
une hausse de la dette une hausse du
communautarisme
triste bilan d'une ville de notre ville
co gérée par la droite et la gauche
depuis 40 ans voilà le bilan d'auxerre
voilà c'est pour ça que nous présentons
nous sommes optimistes nous aussi pour
l'avenir nous avons des choses à
proposer pour cette ville alors vous
avez tous les quatre déjà posé sur la
table un certain nombre de thèmes qui
vont alimenter notre débat ce matin
avant d'entrer vraiment dans le vif du
sujet j'aimerais connaître votre
motivation votre motivation personnelle
tout simplement pour pour conduire une
liste gif et reiz vous vous présenter
pour un troisième mandat ce qu il n'y a
pas une forme d'essoufflement de votre
part il ya toujours la même motivation
chez plutôt le contraire sinon je ne
serai pas candidat à ma succession
j'aimerais rappeler en quelques mots
lorsque j'ai pris mes fonctions en 2001
s'est succédé à mère pour lequel j'ai le
plus grand respect qui était jean
garneau qui a été amère de transition
avant lui vous l'avez réduit les 1001 90
l'agent qui reçoit 2001 avant lui
c'était bien évidemment jean pierre
soisson qui était aussi sur une fin de
cycle et la ville aux faux s'était
endormi pendant ces années et lorsque
j'ai pris mes fonctions en 2001 j'ai
mesuré le retard que notre ville avait
pu prendre et j'ai le sentiment et c'est
le jugement que portent aussi des
auxerrois qui a 62 % considèrent que mon
mandat est plutôt le bilan de mes
mandats est plutôt un bon bilan j'ai
remis du dynamisme du mouvement et de la
modernité dans cette ville ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit ce sont les auxerrois qui
le juge et c'est pour cela
qu'aujourd'hui je vends vie de nouveau
de porter ce mouvement et se dit dhabi
j'ai toujours dit d'ailleurs en
politique il faut quitter la scène
lorsqu'on est là c est lorsqu on laisse
les gens moi je ne suis pas lassé je
n'ai pas le sentiment aujourd'hui de
l'acd auxerrois bio y arriver vous vous
êtes député si vous êtes élu vous devrez
choisir en 2017 entre les deux mandats
pourquoi vous lancer dans cette bataille
je suis le député de surrey le député
des 110 communes qui entourent soeur
puisque c'est ainsi que nos concitoyens
ont décidé lorsque guy ferraz lui-même
souhaitais être député et que je les ai
battus il ya bientôt deux ans lors de
cette élection j'ai succédé à jean
pierre soisson à l'assemblée nationale
et je m'efforce depuis deux ans de
défendre les auxerrois de défendre les
habitants de ma circonscription à
l'assemblée face à un gouvernement le
gouvernement de françois hollande qui je
crois a faibli la france est appauvri
les français alors aujourd'hui je suis
aussi candidat pour devenir le maire
d'auxerre pour devenir le nouveau député
maire d'auxerre entente en effet de
succéder à jean pierre soisson
pleinement comme député et comme député
maire pourquoi parce que je pense que
chaque pierre est apportée par un maire
chaque maire fait quelque chose et je
suis pas dans une critique systématique
de ce qu'a pu faire monsieur ferrat je
respecte sa personne et son action mais
je crois profondément en effet qu'il y a
des cycles il y a eu un cycle jean
pierre soisson il y a aussi un cycle
féroce qui je crois est en train
peut-être de s'achever en tout cas moi
je propose avec une nouvelle équipe un
nouveau projet pour l'avenir douceur ça
ne répond pas à la question 2017 mais
nous y viendrons nous y viendrons
heureux je peux y répondre d'ores et
déjà très facilement vous souhaitiez
vous même guy férez d'être député maire
de seurre je crois les électeurs en ont
décidé autrement moi je crois
profondément qu'il est utile pour la
ville d'être à la fois député en
actionnant un certain nombre de leviers
nationaux nerfs pour gérer le quotidien
et préparer l'avenir 2017 dans trois ans
bien malin qui pourrait dire qui sera
président de la république qui sera
députés quelle sera la loi applicable en
2010 sept mois je suis en 2014 je prends
les sujets un pas après l'autre et en
2017 jeu ferai un choix les auxerrois
feront un choix je ferai le choix qui
sera le meilleur pour notre territoire
ça peut arriver quand même à la raymond
dans certaines villes le front de gauche
est allié avec le parti socialiste c'est
le cas dans la région par exemple à
nevers pourquoi ce choix de mener
campagne sous votre propre bannière
alors je voudrais quand même d'abord
répondre à votre question initiale sur
les ambitions la motivation car nous
n'avons pas d'ambition personnelle nous
sommes unis la motivation je parlais la
motivation oui bah c'est à peu près la
même chose nous n'avons pas d'ambition
personnelle là dedans nous avons fait un
travail depuis plusieurs mois un travail
d'équipé avec les auxerrois en faisant
venir des gens qui pouvaient nous
éclairer sur certain nombre de questions
et en opposant toujours la seule et
unique question qui vaille est ce que
nous ferons de gauche nous pouvons
apporter des choses concrètes aux
auxerrois pour le mieux vivre et le
mieux vivre ensemble pour la démocratie
donc voilà nos ambitions comment mieux
servir la ville et les auxerrois demain
matin et notamment ceux qui sont les
plus en difficulté et il y en a beaucoup
alors pour votre question bien ici il ya
des alliances comme cela là il y en
ad'autres ici nous avons voulu faire une
liste autonome effectivement parce que
d'abord pendant six ans au sein du
conseil municipal
j'ai contesté des choses j'en ai voté
d'autres d'ailleurs un on est tout à
fait d'accord j'ai dû voter sans doute
80% j'ai jamais fait le calcul des
choses qu'ils ont et avant que vous le
disiez
donc j'ai pris en compte un certain
nombre de choses des choses ont été
faites d'ailleurs jamais dit le
contraire mais je pense que nous nous
avons une vraie vision d'une société de
demain nous avons des inquiétudes par
rapport à la politique du gouvernement
aujourd'hui qui va ne peut qu'y ne
s'arrangera pas après les élections
puisque on nous dit 50 milliards qui va
falloir aller chercher et c'est sur le
bien public c'est sûr la chose publique
sur les services publics que l'état va
aller les chercher donc on espère qu'on
sera là demain pour contrecarrer cette
politique là allez pour finir le tour de
table julien guibert alors jusqu alors
il y avait un seul conseiller municipal
fn à auxerre c'est richard jacobs il a
été exclu c'est vous qui menez cette
liste donc pour quoi faire quelle est
votre aussi votre motivation écoutez
pour la première fois de notre histoire
de notre histoire politique je pense
qu'il nous est donné pour le front
national d'avoir un groupe d'opposition
à la mairie quel que soit le maire qui
sera élu il y aura un groupe
d'opposition front national à la mairie
nous nous présentons pourquoi
nous sommes des enfants d'auxerre pour
la plupart des auxerre roi de souche
nous avons à coeur avec notre équipe de
redonner vie et de redonner un nouveau
souffle à notre ville de proposer une
alternative politique une alternative
populaire et patriote marine le pen a
fait 17 % aux présidentielles à auxerre
et ne comptons bien plus qu égalé ce
score voilà et représenter le front
national à la mairie avec un vrai groupe
d'opposition alors vous me permettez
justement une transition parce qu'il ne
vous a pas échappé en fait il se steria
a réalisé cette semaine un sondage
exclusif pour france 3 bourgogne au
premier tour il donne 45% d'intentions
de vote haggui férès 35% à guillaume
larrivé 10% à julien guibert 9% alain
rémond et 1 % à la liste de lutte
ouvrière dont nous entendrons la
candidate tout à l'heure au second tour
ipsos steria a fait deux hypothèses en
cas de triangulaire gif erez serait
réélu à 51% guillaume larrivé ray
recueillerait 40% et julien guibert 9%
et en cas de duel gif erez l'emporterait
avec 53% des voix contre 47 pour
guillaume larrivé différence vous avez
réagi à ce sondage comme les autres
candidats cette semaine vous avez dit ni
rondelle ne fait pas le printemps tout
de même est-ce que vous avez été
soulagés de ce sondage de ces de ses
prévisions d'abord je vous confirme
qu'une hirondelle ne fait pas le
printemps parce qu' hier il faisait un
temps splendide sur auxerre aujourd'hui
de retrouver la fraîcheur dont il faut
toujours se méfier des signes
annonciateurs et si une hirondelle ne
fait pas le printemps un sondage ou des
intentions de vote ne font jamais une
élection tant que le dernier bulletin
comme l'on dit n'est pas tombé dans leur
vous faites partie de ces mères qui
craignent une démobilisation à gauche
pas particulièrement pas
particulièrement mais encore une fois la
campagne n'est pas terminée il s'agit là
d'un sondage c'est une image à un moment
donné une campagne électorale vous le
savez c'est un film entier c'est à
scénario il leur reste huit jours pour
conforter le cas échéant des intentions
de vote mais je continue la campagne
telle que je la conduis depuis le début
de cette campagne électorale pour les
municipales
guillaume larrivé
l'ump a désigné auxerre comme une de ses
cibles un privilégié est ce que vous
l'avez accueillie comme une mauvaise
nouvelle ce sondage je suis challenger
je me vis comme dida l de lait puis le
début c'est bien normal je suis le
candidat à la tête d'une nouvelle union
pour au sort avec de nouvelles personnes
compétentes venant de tous les quartiers
fasse un candidat sortant le candidat du
parti socialiste qui siège au conseil
municipal depuis 31 ans et qui est le
maire dosser depuis 13 ans donc il est
tout à fait normal que je sois perçu
comme challenger je l'étais aussi
d'ailleurs pour l'élection à l'assemblée
nationale et vous savez personne de
décidera à la place des auxerrois les
auxerrois sont libres de leur choix on a
cette chance immense d'avoir ce grand
rendez vous démocratique dans notre
ville c'est le 23 mars dimanche en huit
que les auxerrois et les auxerrois
diront qu'à l'avenir avec quelle équipe
ils veulent construire alors aimons vous
vous vous êtes crédité de 9% à par ipsos
et steria vous aviez obtenu cet ennemi
en 2008 finalement c'est plutôt aussi
plutôt pas mal et pourtant vous dites
que vous êtes déçu alors vous espérer
passer le cap du des 10% pour pouvoir
vous maintenir donc d'abord on avance
effectivement n'était à cet ennemi en
2008 vous avez raison 9 % on nous donne
9% aujourd'hui on n'a encore rien vu
parce qu'il ya encore une semaine et des
choses bougent et se passe en ce moment
dans votre sondage je ne sais pas ce que
vous faites de nouveau deuxième tour
d'ailleurs parce qu'on nous
disparaissons mairie vous avez passé
mais nous espérons effectivement bon
c'est un sondage suis d'accord avec tout
le monde c'est une photo un moment donné
il ya encore huit jours et ses pairs et
saas mais nous sommes convaincus
aujourd'hui et nous ferons tout pour ça
que nous passerons les 10% et au-delà
des 10% et là le jeu deviendra très
intéressant pour les auxerrois
10% c'est c'est vraiment l'objectif que
vous vous fixez 10% et au delà pour pour
passage au deuxième tour jules univers
alors alors non du tout déjà j'aimerais
revenir sur les intentions de vote de
monsieur l'arrivée puisque je pense que
c'est directement une sanction de son
taux d'absentéisme au conseil municipal
puisque durant la dernière mandature il
étaient présents qu'à 21 une reprise sur
les 36 ans au conseil municipal
effectivement il est bien présent à
l'assemblée nationale à paris mais il
brille par son absence à auxerre donc il
est bien présent à paris mais pas
auxerre nous ce qu'on veut c'est des
gens du cru des gens locaux on s'appelle
moi la réponse
moi je ne veux pas polémiquer ce qui
m'intéresse de construire l'avenir je ne
vais pas me justifier je ne vais pas
m'excuser d'être ce que je suis je suis
oui le député je suis aussi candidat
pour devenir le nouveau maire de seurre
sinon pour répondre quand même pour
leurs éditions de sondage nous sommes
minorées nous sommes minorées une somme
à 10% d'intentions de vote vous savez
j'ai un de mes proches qui a été sondé
la méthodologie de sondage les personnes
reçoivent un coup de fil on leur demande
si c'est bien tel nom tel prénom vous
êtes bien domicilié à telle adresse vous
avez inscrit dans tel bureau de vote
d'accor pour qui allez vous voter moi je
peux vous dire que bon nombre
d'électeurs du front national sont pas
encore prêts à dire un inconnu au
téléphone pour qu'ils vont voter donc je
peux vous dire dans moins que dans un
sondage nous avons été donnée à 12% la
présidentielle à auxerre et nous avons
fait 17 % donc nous sommes minorées de 3
à 5% ça c'est une certitude et avec ce
sondage nous sommes déjà donné au second
tour nous serons au second tour et on a
fait un score bien au delà de ça
d'ailleurs je veux pour preuve en 2011
il y avait deux cantons à auxerre où
nous étions second tour où nous avons
passé la barre des 30% à auxerre donc
nous serons bien ou second tour nous
serons là au second tour à auxerre et
vous maintiendrez et nous maintiendrons
aller venons en aux thèmes locaux on va
dire le budget ça a été la dernière
controverse de votre mandat gif erez
votre position à boycotter le dernier
conseil municipal le 20 février dernier
parce que vous avez repoussé le budget à
l'après-élection on peut penser que vous
avez quelque chose à cacher ses seins
je n'ai absolument rien à cacher je dis
votre opposition mais c'est normal une
opposition est là pour s'opposer et en
principe critiquer celui qui exerce le
pouvoir qu'elles cherchent elles mêmes à
conquérir j'ai toujours dit depuis le
mois de décembre depuis le mois de
novembre
j'ai toujours dit qu'il revenait à la
prochaine équipe de construire son but g
et cela est si vrai que avant le 31
décembre s'est tenue une commission des
finances monsieur l'arrivée qui étaient
présents à cette commission des finances
la seule commission des finances à
laquelle il a participé depuis le début
du mandat d'ailleurs est bien le
président de la commission des finances
a annoncé aux commissaires bande de la
commission des finances
que j'avais souhaité que je sois la
prochaine équipe dix baptistes ce budget
et guillaume larrivé présent au sein de
cette commission des finances a dit
finalement c'est logique il appartient
bien à la future équipe de conclure le
budget 2014 guillaume larrivé
le candidat du parti socialiste est mal
à l'aise moi je pense que nous avons
dans cette campagne vis-à-vis des
auxerrois un devoir de vérité et la
vérité que j'ai révélé c'est qu'au 31
décembre 2013 la dette municipale à
auxerre a atteint un niveau record
64,8 millions d'euros la vérité monsieur
ferraz c'est que dans les trois derniers
mois de l'année 2013 vous êtes allé
faire le tour des banques le crédit
mutuel la banque postale la banque
populaire la caisse des dépôts et
consignations pour aller contracté 13
millions d'euros d'emprunts nouveaux
vous en avez remboursé 5 le niveau de la
dette atteint un niveau record et ma
responsabilité eric sicaud si je suis le
nouveau maire dosser dans quelques jours
ce sera en urgence d'élaborer le budget
2014 de la ville de manière sérieuse de
manière responsable parce que mon
prédécesseur
contrairement à tous les usages
contrairement à toutes les pratiques
républicaines n'aura pas préparer le
budget et laissera une ville surendettée
moi je suis pour qu'on investisse je
connais votre rhétorique je suis pour
qu'on investisse je ne suis pas pour
qu'on gaspille et je ne suis pas pour
qu'on surendette je servirai une réponse
tout de même à l'église amant vous le
devinez je veux relever d'emblée
plusieurs fois je le fais avec beaucoup
de sérénité parce que monsieur guillaume
larrivé on ne peut pas ignorer tout cela
pourquoi nous empruntons en fin d'année
parce que la ville dispose d'une
trésorerie suffisante pour
éviter en cours d'année d'emprunter ce
qui nous fait gagner sur les intérêts
bien évidemment deuxièmement j'ai pas
fait le tour des banques c'est tout
simplement mis en concurrence l'ensemble
du secteur bancaire pour tirer les
meilleurs taux d'intérêt ça c'est un
souci de bonne gestion sur la dette nous
y reviendrons sans doute tout à l'heure
lorsque nous aborderons les thèmes
locaux en matière de développement en
matière d'investissement je ne suis pas
du tout en train de m'excuser de ce que
j'ai fait j'ai investi parce que cette
ville avait pris énormément de retard
et au fond quand l'emprunt représente 64
millions d'euros à rembourser c'était
déjà le cas en 2009 sauf qu'entre 2009
et 2013 eh bien j'ai fait descendre
l'emprunt et donc la dette à rembourser
l'emprunt à rembourser et tomber
beaucoup plus bas et donc là aussi c'est
un peu comme un sondage ce n'est pas
l'image qui compte c'est le scénario sur
l'ensemble du mandat est donc encore une
fois je n'excuse pas d'avoir investi
dans cette ville parce qu'investir c'est
le soutenir l'économie c'est soutenir
l'emploi et nous y reviendrons
à la raymond oui dans alors plusieurs
choses sur le budget est effectivement
j'ai protesté et depuis le début j'étais
le premier je crois sur le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas de budget et que
l'opposition ne puisse pas travailler
avec des documents réels et en temps en
temps réel donc ça c'est sur le plan de
la démocratie quelque chose qui n'est
pas bien c'est clair je leur dis
d'ailleurs c'est une vieille méthode
qu'utilise est aussi d'ailleurs jean
pierre soisson qui disait les des années
d'élections sur pas de budget et puis le
lendemain des élections le présentait
donc ça c'est une première chose c'est
pas là le plus grave y'a la dette on
verra quand on aura les chiffres réels
puisqu'on nous dit qu'on les aura
conjoint et on regardera ça la dette à
la limite elle me pose pas de problème
si ce sont des investissements qui
permettent demain du développement etc
ceci étant dit on verra quelle hauteur
et on verra si on a pas fait des
dépenses tout à fait aberrantes dans
certains domaines et 6 n'a pas dépassé
ce qui
est le plus grave le plus grave n'est
pas encore là c'est quand je vois que
guy ferrer prévoit dans les invités dans
les investissements à partir de 2014 et
pour les années du mandat qui vient les
années qui viennent 10 millions
d'investissements par an seulement alors
que nous avons fait dans les dernières
années une moyenne de 16 millions
d'investissements alors là je pose la
question pourquoi on va baisser les
interstices ment à ce point c'est à dire
33% à peu près ça c'est une vraie
question parce que ces investissements à
venir vont nous manquer différence juste
un mot d'abord de ford à julien guibert
à ce propos alors sur la dette
effectivement le maire d'auxerre est le
meilleur ami des banquiers on a besoin
d'une
d'une extension de budget on va voir
monsieur banques et on prend un nouveau
crédit c'est pas des choses convenable
pour ma part ce que je pense mais
également il n'y a pas que la gauche y
llach la droite ils sont à la tête du
conseil général ils ont été à la tête de
l'état pendant longtemps c'est aussi des
organismes qui sont de l'état qui sont
totalement endettés donc c'est ce que je
disais ce sont des collections de la
droite et de la gauche l'a mérité déjà
endetté à hauteur de 40 millions d'euros
sous la droite faut pas l'oublier donc
c'est une cogestion ump s est également
sur le budget j'aimerais dire qu'en dix
ans le budget de fonctionnement a
augmenté de 22 % ce qui n'est pas rien
nous allons attendre les 59 millions
d'euros il y a des vraies économies à
faire voilà nous nous proposons
d'économiser dans le budget de
fonctionnement tout en gardant à tout
service de très bonne qualité pour les
excès roi il ya des économies à faire
notamment sur les frais de réception les
frais de subventions aux associations
les frais de mission les indemnités tu
sais j'ai avec moi j'invite la
population à venir le retirer à la
mairie tout citoyen est en droit veut
devenir le chercher les comptes
administratifs de la commune jean
question parce que j'ai trouvé des
lignes qui sont très intéressants en
tant que citoyen g22 de questions sur
les comptes administratifs le 21 juin
2002 2012 est en ligne alors je suis
bête et discipliné je lis bêtement cette
ligne ya marqué mobilier pour drh qui a
inventé un mille 559 euros 41 mille 559
euros de mobilier alors j'aimerais
savoir ce que c'est en tant en termes de
mobilier une deuxième ligne qui met
appel le 13 décembre 2012 refonder
portail des sites internet de la commune
38 1807 euros alors si c'est pour faire
le site internet de la commune je peux
vous donner des adresses d'entreprises
pour dix fois moins cher ils font le
site internet de la mairie 1,38 1807
euros pour un site internet je me
demande où va vous allez répondre guigui
farez mais à un mot si vous avez demandé
la parole avec guy willy a eu à
l'évidence un certain nombre de
gaspillage vous l'indiquer
les auxerrois ont aussi à l'esprit le
400000 euros de la fontaine les murs de
cuivre de la maison de quartier rive
droite etc mais au-delà de cela il faut
bien comprendre que nos territoires ils
sont en compétition et lorsqu'on a une
dette très élevée 40% supérieur à la
dette des villes de même taille eh bien
ça veut dire qu'on s'est attaché un
certain nombre de boulet au pied et ça
c'est très très contraignant
naturellement pour l'action future c'est
pour ça que si je deviens moeurs mon
premier devoir ça sera de gérer
sérieusement les finances en refusant
toute augmentation d'impôts et en
baissant un certain nombre de dépenses
de fonctionnement un seul exemple je
supprimerai l'indemnité du maire je
réduirai le nombre des adjoints
rémunérés et j'économiserai ainsi huit
cent mille euros durant le mandat huit
cent mille euros que je peut réinvestir
dans la vie quotidienne par exemple dans
les travaux de voirie à une réponse
rapide s'il vous plaît ferait que je
réponde quand même sur les trois bien
trois fois pardon d'abord pour répondre
à l'arrêt mans pourquoi je prévoit dans
le prochain mandat une moyenne de 10
millions d'euros d'investissements
contre un rythme qui jusqu'à présent
étaient à 15 milliards d'euros tout
simplement parce que l'essentiel des
projets que j'ai voulu monter lorsque je
suis devenu maire les gros
investissements sont désormais derrière
nous le contexte d'ailleurs aussi des
finances publiques y compris sur le plan
national conduit demain également à
réduire la voilure je voudrais voilà je
voudrais je voudrais continuer aussi il
ya deux manières quand on investit de
manière de procéder en termes de gestion
soit en recours à l'emprunt comme je lé
fais pour une large part parce que quand
on investit sur des équipements qui vont
durer 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans il me semble
normal que cela soit supportée par
toutes les générations qui vont utiliser
ces équipements il ya des maires qu'il
faut d'autres choix et qui actionne la
pompe des appeaux et donc il faut payer
aux contribuables du présent les
investissements qui vont également
servir pour demain
d'ailleurs sur les un peu je crois que
vous êtes tous d'accord pour ne pas les
augmenter dans les années qui viennent
alors on va parler économie
développement attractivité quand même
parce que je voulais souligner si vous
grattez je trouve extraordinaire quand
même que monsieur l'arrivée nous parle
de la tête comme cela lui qui a été au
coeur du pouvoir pendant les années
sarkozy le pouvoir qui nous a mis 500
milliards de dette supplémentaire sur le
dos en cinq ans a livré une petite
réponse j'assume complètement le fait
d'avoir été conseiller du président de
la république très franchement quand je
compare la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
et quand je regarde la présidence
hollande je le dis devant le le
président du comité de soutien à
françois hollande franchement je
considère qu'il n'y a pas photo et
j'assume complètement le fait d'être un
député proche encore du président
nicolas sarkozy
il y aurait en france 1 je pense que ça
crève les yeux dans les rues en france 1
allez on va parler économie attractivité
comme je le disais je vous propose
d'accueillir philippe rey gorrez le
rédacteur en chef de france bleu auxerre
et pendant qu'ils s'installent nous
allons écouter s'il vit manigod elle
représente la cinquième liste de cette
élection municipale la liste de lutte
ouvrière qui a décidé de ne pas parler
de politique locale qui ne changera rien
selon elle au quotidien des travailleurs
lutte ouvrière développe donc des
arguments de politique générale on
écoute sylvie manico nouveautés lutte
ouvrière
c'est qu'il faudrait faire imposer
l'interdiction des licenciements
imposer la répartition du travail entre
tous sans
réduction de salaire
imposer le relevé du secret bancaire
imposée l'augmentation des salaires pour
les indexées sur les prix afin que la
classe populaire puisse vivre dignement
votez lutte ouvrière s'est montré que
les travailleurs en ont assez de se
faire dépouiller par la bourgeoisie que
par les politiciens à son service
votez lutte ouvrière s'est affirmé que
le travail ne se laisse ce pu berner et
qui sont prêts à relever la tête
alors nous avons plusieurs questions qui
nous parviennent sur internet sur
l'emploi et le développement économique
philippe rey gorrez je vous laisse la
parole à ce sujet bonjour taux de
chômage de grosso modo 9 9% juste sous
la barre des 10% à auxerre c'est grosso
modo le même qu'au niveau national
c'est je pense que vous serez tous
d'accord c'est trop beaucoup trop on
compte sur les entreprises pour créer de
l'emploi comment s'y prend on pour
dynamiser sur le plan économique une
ville comme auxerre je propose de
commencer par vous guillaume larrivé
quelles sont vos propositions pour le
dynamisme j'ai noté notamment la votre
programme que vous comptiez beaucoup sur
la promotion du rayonnement de la ville
au plus haut niveau ça veut dire quoi
mon sujet numéro un c'est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui la jeunesse dosser elle a
plutôt envie de quitter auxerre c'est ça
le vrai sujet
comment fait-on pour projeter notre
ville
dans un avenir qui fasse que les jeunes
aient envie et la possibilité de rester
ici et donc il faut qu'on agit sur
plusieurs leviers faut qu'on soit
capable de faire venir des entreprises
notamment des entreprises industrielles
sur la zone d'activités d'appoigny qui
est en train de se construire il faut
qu'on soit capable aussi de dynamiser
les lieux de formation d'apprentissage
d'enseignement supérieur il faut qu'on
soit capable d'accélérer le déploiement
du numérique il faut qu'on soit capable
d'assumer notre position dans une
compétition qui est très importante
aujourd'hui les entreprises elles ont
plutôt envie d'aller à 3 d'aller à
chartres même d'aller à sens il faut
qu'elle ait demain envie qu'elle faisait
la possibilité de s'installer ici c'est
très compliqué à réaliser alors comment
s'y prend pour assurer cette promotion
pour donner envie aux entreprises ils
font pressants plusieurs sujets je pense
notamment que la question du coeur de
ville est une question importante vous
retrouver au coeur de la ville qui est à
moteur est une vitrine pour l'ensemble
de la ville une attractivité que nous
avons perdu il faut que la fiscalité
soit accueillante et donc qu'on ne
charge pas la barque il faut aussi
encore une fois que sur l'enseignement
sur la formation supérieure on remette
autour de la table le monde de
l'entreprise le monde de l'université
pour adapter nos filières d'enseignement
aux besoins des entreprises
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et puis c'est
vrai il faut aussi assumer une politique
de marketing de promotion du territoire
au plus haut niveau en faisant
retravailler ensemble le président du
conseil régional le président du conseil
général les milieux économiques et je
pense comme député marc dosser que ce
serait mon premier job différence je
pense que vous pouvez adhérer à ce que
vient de dire guillaume larrivé n'en
qu'est ce qui peut vous différencier sur
ce point je vais même aller plus loin
parce que j'ai l'impression que
lassitude rhétorique est en train de se
développer et donc j'essayais d'être un
peu plus concret d'abord je voudrais
corriger un tout petit peu votre chiffre
9,9 pour cent c'est sur ce qu'on appelle
la zone d'emploi et donc il recouvre
également des territoires comme tonnerre
comme saint florentin sur
l'agglomération parce c'est ce qui
m'intéresse puisque je suis en même
temps près dans l'agglomération le taux
de chômage est plutôt inférieur d'entre
9 3 et 9 5 j'ajoute que c'est inférieur
à la moyenne nationale inférieur à la
moyenne régionale est inférieure à la
moyenne départementale
guillaume larrivé disait en regardant ce
qui se passe sur sens à 179 en matière
de taux de chômage et donc si auxerre
n'est pas à l'écart du phénomène que
nous connaissons sur l'ensemble du pays
j'aimerais quand même rappeler qu
auxerre reste le premier pôle économique
et commerciale du département
l'agglomération d'auxerre très
exactement entre 35 et 36 mille emplois
dont 26 milan point sur la seule ville
d'auxerre est bien évidemment nous avons
connu dans le passé un sombre de
difficultés avec des entreprises qui ont
fermé mais j'aimerais rappeler aussi
qu'il ya de l'emploi qui était créé on
m'a beaucoup critiqué
quand j'ai ouvert à l'urbanisation
économique le secteur des clairions ses
800 emplois qui ont été créés 800
emplois salariés privés
mais il ya également des emplois publics
ou parapublics conti tôt quand j'ai pris
mes fonctions de président du conseil
d'administration de l'hôpital en 2001
c'était exactement 1200 salariés qui
travaillaient aujourd'hui parce que nous
avons avec tonnerre avalant dans le cas
d'un grand coup plan de coopération
sanitaire l'hôpital d'auxerre ses 1800
emplois rien que sur ces deux exemples
là ses 1400 employés des entreprises
aussi qui se sont développés alors
comment agir demain j'ai fait adopter
par le conseil communautaire à
l'agglomération ma décembre à
l'unanimité une stratégie de
développement économique qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça ça veut dire qu'il faut
répondre aux besoins des entreprises
notamment en matière de foncier c'est
tout l'enjeu est tout l'objet du parc
d'activités d'appoigny pour la création
de 1500 emplois c'est également
travailler sur les besoins immobiliers
de l'entreprise bien évidemment c'est
aussi permettent à création d'activités
nouvelles défendre aussi ceux qui
existent déjà bien évidemment c'est
repéré aussi les secteurs qu'il faut
aider ceux qui sont en émergence c'est
aussi bien évidemment fixer un cap y ait
des qui a tiré ce aussi oui faire du
marketing territorial est allé chercher
sur à poisy deux axes de développement
et d'importation d'entreprise
développement des entreprises locales et
aller chercher à l'extérieur notamment
du côté l'ile-de-france des entreprises
nouvelles c'est cela que nous allons
être à c'est ça le sens de la stratégie
développement économique de
l'agglomération
d'abord julien guibert alors auxerre vit
sous perfusion de l'état les plus gros
employeurs de notre commune sont les
temps heureusement que nous sommes une
ville préfecture si nous ne serons pas
une ville préfecture auxerre serait
sûrement nord c'est une chance à permet
dé était jack ou des crises mais tout à
fait c'est une grande chance que au cir
est une ville préfecture heureusement
qu'il y à l'emploi des fonctionnaires à
auxerre
tout simplement ce que je voudrais dire
le taux de chômage est également minoré
puisqu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
radiées du chômage donc ils ne sont pas
dans les chiffres est ce que je dénonce
c'est la grande précarité de beaucoup de
salariés d'auxerre nous avons beaucoup
de personnes à auxerre qui ont des
emplois précaires des temps partiels des
cdd des petits cdd à rallonge voilà ce
qu'est l'emploi des hawks est roi
beaucoup je me réjouis pas de cet emploi
là nous pour la création d'emplois donc
effectivement on appuie la création de
cette zone appoigny
la chose que l'on que l'on regrette
effectivement auxerre en train de
prendre un virage numérique avec la
fibre optique qui entraîne d'arrivée qui
est déjà installée dans certains
quartiers de la ville nous nous en
félicitons parce que c'est vraiment un
beau projet pour les auxerrois mais nous
aimerons créer un pôle consacré
exclusivement à l'économie numérique car
auxerre est en train de louper ce virage
économique ça représente 4 % des impôts
en france et plus de 50 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires est fait en france
sur le pôle numérique donc nous aimerons
développer une zone d'activités dédiée à
à cela est notamment lié à ça il y aura
de l'emploi logistique qui se créera et
j'aimerais également faire une
parenthèse je suis le seul candidat
l'avoir mis dans mon programme ça
comprend un petit peu que l'économie mme
c'est plus un vecteur populaire le
retour de la foire d'auxerre sur les
boulevards ça faisait vivre les
commerces le temps d'un week-end stop à
la foire d'auxerre à auxerre expo et
vive le retour de la foire d'auxerre sur
les boulevards c'est un vrai retour aux
sources populaires à la raymond nous
tournons vers vous et quels sont vos
projets pour dynamiser économiquement la
ville d'auxerre alors dynamiser la ville
d'auxerre suffira pas il y avait un
problème de politique nationale quand
même avant et j'aimerais bien qu'on
n'oublie pas parce qu'aujourd'hui la
politique de l'offre dans laquelle nous
dirigent aujourd'hui l'un françois
hollande oui mais tout est lié on n'est
pas à une île isolée de tout on est dans
un monde complet français européen et
c'est la politique de l'offre
aujourd'hui qui consiste dans les
derniers temps à faire 30 milliards de
cadeaux aux entreprises en leur enlevant
la les îles et les allocations
et pour la famille ça c'est une vraie
catastrophe c'est donc une vraie une
véritable politique de la demande qui va
falloir relancer parce que les
entreprises ne créent de l'emploi que
s'il ya du monde comment bien évidemment
un trépas de l'emploi comme ça ex nihilo
donc il faut changer de politique
nationale premièrement deuxième ce n'est
pas le maire de sacchi non mais
c'est pas lui mais il faisait puisque le
maire d'auxerre effectivement un soutien
à cette politique là il a dit il ya peu
qu'il était déçu lors facile avait été
député leur est votée les mêmes que ce
que votre épée les mêmes lois que ce que
vote les députés socialistes aujourd'hui
donc bientôt voter pour moi à
l'assemblée nationale c'est donc voilà
c'est la politique nationale qui créent
qui changent les choses la politique
économique et localement effectivement
il ya des choses à faire mais monter une
zone industrielle / à poigne et je suis
tout à fait d'accord c'est pas ça qui va
créer forcément demain 15 100 emplois
parce qu'elle sera là c'est une autre
politique économique aussi nationale et
bien évidemment on a dix atouts locaux
qu'il faut mettre en avant et notamment
en jeu par la voie de la formation
professionnelle je pense pas que je sois
en avance sur le temps ci
donc c'est à guillaume larrivé
maintenant à travers la formation parce
que ce sont des gens qualifiés que les
entreprises viendront chercher plutôt
qu'autre chose guillaume larrivé je vous
ai vu faire la moue tout à l'heure quand
guy férès disait que l'emploi public
était un amortisseur de crise pas trop
votre avis nord de remarques sur la zone
d'activités d'appoigny ça va coûter et
ça c'est un investissement utile à peu
près 25 à 30 millions d'euros à
l'échelle de la communauté
d'agglomération le vrai sujet maintenant
c'est de faire venir effectivement des
entreprises lorsque le candidat
socialiste à l'instant dix mille cinq
cents emplois j'aimerais en connaître
les modes de calcul la vérité c'est que
comme député-maire mon job ce sera
d'aller chercher des investisseurs pour
qu'ils viennent s'installer sur cette
zone d'activités de l'auxerrois première
marque deuxième remarque et là je
voudrais poser une question au candidat
sortant s'agissant du commerce nous
sommes ici au coeur de ville il ya
environ
70 75 petits commerces de proximité qui
sont aujourd'hui fermés ici nous sommes
à deux pas de dubost qui est fermé
depuis
des années je pense que la zone des
clairions le parc commercial déclarions
est arrivé à maturité il a trouvé son
public je critique pas en soit le parent
déclarions il existe il est là je pense
qu'il est arrivé à maturité et
j'aimerais que les choses soient
précises et je suis pour ma part hostile
à une extension artificielle du parc
commercial des clairions j'aimerais que
vous précisiez votre position et je vais
vous poser de questions très précises
avez vous oui ou non d'ores et déjà
signé ou fait signer par un adjoint a
permis de construire pour étendre le
parc commercial des clairions avec une
société la société frey deuxième
question qu'allez vous dire le 26 mars
lorsqu au tribunal administratif de
dijon vous êtes convoqué pour vous
expliquer sur cette extension du parc
des clairions guillaume larrivé pose les
questions oh mes questions précises
auxquelles je répond de manière précise
et avec un immense plaisir
il y a ceux qui disent comme lio
l'arrivée moi je dis et je fais les
papilles tard qu'hier après midi j'avais
dans mon bureau
le représentant de la société à laquelle
vous faites allusion
je peux vous dire qu'ils sont tombés de
leur siège
puisque j'aurais dit très clairement
qu'il était hors de question que je leur
vente des terrains aux clairions pour y
installer sa bile mètres carrés
supplémentaires
et donc ce que vous évoquez autour du
permis de construire aujourd'hui n'a
plus de raison d'être je le dis j'ai
aperçu quelques commerçants présents
autour de nous les clairions c'est
terminé et je les dis hier aux
représentants de la société frey jeudi
et je fais à la raymond rapidement oui
pour ce qui est du coeur de ville je
veux une demain nous ferons tout pour
cela que l'on revienne sur le projet de
l'arc buses vous vous vous avez la
transition c'est une gamelle
du bon bah voilà c'est fait c'est fait
maintenant reprenons ce projet avec les
auxerrois avec les commerçants pour
redonner un coup monde plus à la ville
une animation de plus à la ville un
véritable parking à cet endroit là là je
crois pour le développement du coeur de
ville c'est le seul sujet aujourd'hui au
moins un des seuls au moins l'essentiel
à prendre en main demain pour arriver à
quelque chose et qu'il soit pas le
projet que vous avez voulu un moment
imposé à tous alors vous avez tous
effectivement des projets pour le coeur
de ville pour le centre-ville tout
simplement avec des options un petit peu
différente guillaume larrivé vous voulez
redonner vie à coeur de ville la place
saint-pierre la place du maréchal
leclerc différait zh vous misez sur la
place des cordeliers etc vous voulez
écrire une grosse place centrale
j'allais dire guillaume larrivé préciser
votre projet parce que voilà il ya quand
même des options différentes
d'abord il ya deux méthodes la méthode
c'est de faire le contraire de ce que le
candidat sortant avait souhaité imposer
à l'arc buses suscitant une forme de
révolte des auxerrois moi je ne veux pas
imposer je veux proposer je veux faire
adhérer je veux construire ce projet de
redynamisation du coeur de ville avec
les auxerrois et pour cela je me
donnerai quelques mois après l'élection
pour préciser de manière détaillée
juridiquement solide financièrement
solide le projet ce que je sais d'abord
c'est ce que je ne veux pas je ne veux
pas ouvrir un chantier place des
cordeliers car je considère que notre
ville est trop fragile financièrement
trop fragile commercialement trop
fragile pour supporter trois ou quatre
années de travaux place des cordeliers
peut-être aurait-il fallu le faire il ya
dix ans il ya 15 ans il ya vingt ans peu
importe aujourd'hui en 2014 je ne veux
pas ouvrir ce chantier et je propose
cela aux auxerrois ce que je veux faire
c'est deux choses d'abord multiplier des
espaces de stationnement pour simplifier
la vie des auxerrois au quotidien et
deuxièmement embellir le coeur de ville
en travaillant en effet sur certaines
places rénovées aussi le marché actuel
de l'arc bus concentré certain nombre
d'investissements en effet sur le
centre-ville le coeur de ville qui
appartient à tous les auxerrois et qui a
été négligée ces dernières années
différents une vraie il ya une vraie
différence au moins là dans les
programmes à propos de cette place des
cordeliers c'est mieux même si j'ai noté
que dans le programme qui est celui de
mon challenger les verbes re poursuivre
continuez développés étaient très
présents donc c'est plutôt bon signe
j'ai envie de dire sur ce que j'ai fait
j'en viens à 100 sur leur commerce
regarder la boutique est en face de nous
aux castors elle est fermée pourquoi les
fermer parce qu'au dessus il y a un
appartement
et la dame qui tenait le magasin
habitait au dessus ce commerce est vide
parce que sur le plan physique on ne
peut pas voir à la fois commerce et puis
on ne peut pas avoir un appartement au
dessus à quelques encablures d'ici
guillaume larrivé citer l'ancien magasin
dubost pourquoi aujourd'hui et il vide
c'est la réalité du marché locatif
auxerrois 8000 euros de loyers demandés
par mois et en même temps quand vous
payer 8000 euros de loyer par mois il
faut investir plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros pour pouvoir y
installer quelque chose c'est ça c'est
une des réalités de notre coeur de ville
ce sont des loyers progrès vous proposer
une préhension ces sas je propose est
plus je vous êtes d'accord en charge
lors que cela sera utile je pense qu'il
faut que la ville mettre en oeuvre ce
qu'on appelle le droit de préemption
commercial quelque chose d'assez
compliqué et illimitée dans le temps et
ne faut pas l'utiliser n'importe comment
il faut l'utiliser chaque fois que peut
disparaître un commerce considéré comme
stratégique on dit qu en coeur de ville
je vous annonce est aussi quelque chose
annoncé tout à l'heure clarion c'était
fini à quelques encablures également
d'ici là devant moi dans quelques
semaines va s'ouvrir il rue enfin en
coeur de ville un nouveau commerce de
bouche et c'est un traiteur ce coeur de
ville doit se spécifié se spécialiser
sur un centre de commerce contre disparu
c'est ça aussi la réalité quotidienne
julien oui je dénonce également la même
chose le centre-ville est en train de
mourir commercialement nous assistons un
centre ville qui qui a plus qu'une
fonction administratif donc les auxerre
c'est la préfecture c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas que les auxerrois qui vient en
centre ville il y a également les gens
qui viennent de l'extérieur notamment de
puiser du tonnerrois etc qui viennent
dans le centre-ville d'auxerre
aujourd'hui non plus place pour se garer
donc ils vont directement à la zone des
clairions donc auxerre summer dû au
manque de places de parking
duala au moment d'une disponibilité de
places nous nous proposons qu'il avait
beaucoup plus régulière sur les parkings
périphériques du centre-ville et comme
le parking roscoff le parking des des
anciennes usines guillet également une
refonte j'ai effectivement un projet qui
ressemble à celui de monsieur raymond
hains
le projet de la refonte de la place
d'arqués buzek création de parts qui
touche nos chiffres on a 150 nouvelles
places de parking à l'arc buse est
surveillé par un gardien parce que vous
avez dans le niveau du parking d'arqués
bus sous le marché c'est sombre il y a
de la sécurité ça sent mauvais ça donne
pas envie d'y aller et je pense qu'il
faut redonner aux excès roi ce parking
pour donner l'accessibilité aux
commerces et l'accessibilité également
aux services publics tout simplement
guillaume larrivé je suis heureux de
faire progresser le débat nous sommes
tous au service des auxerrois et je ne
doute pas de la bonne volonté des uns et
des autres j'ai lancé dès le mois de
novembre
en ouvrant ma campagne avec le député
maire de troyes françois baroin j'ai
lancé le débat sur le coeur de ville
j'ai proposé que l'on arrête l'extension
de la zone des clairions je constate que
le le candidat sortant se rallient à
cette idée tant mieux pour la ville tant
mieux pour la ville maintenant l'urgence
en effet c'est le coeur de notre ville
et je voudrais que vous précisiez vos
intentions sur les cordeliers
car là encore il ne faut pas en fumée
les auxerrois et les auxerrois vous
annoncez un débat moi je souhaite que ce
débat n'ait pas lieu s'agissant de la
place des cordeliers car encore une fois
j'ai la conviction que la ville est trop
fragile pour que trois quatre années de
travaux viennent fragiliser encore plus
le coeur de ville essayons de faire des
choses plus rapide moins coûteuse avec
bon sens en travaillant notamment sur
des petites places la place saint pierre
la place un taux faible à plat sans
doute aussi du maréchal leclerc
qui est à proximité de nous ici les
cordeliers je crois vraiment que
peut-être vous auriez dû le faire y à il
ya dix ans il ya 15 ans il ya vingt ans
il ya trente ans quand vous étiez déjà
aux affaires mais qu'aujourd'hui en 2014
ça n'est pas une bonne idée allegri
ferries et une réponse qu'après en avant
ne peut pas papa de shoushi ne vous
inquiétez pas je voulais tout simplement
redire que deux choses d'abord il ne
faut pas oublier qu'une des raisons qui
rendent la vie difficile en terme
commercial tout le monde sait bien c'est
le développement du commerce par le net
j'aimerais rappeler qu'en huit ans le
commerce sur le net été multiplié par
six étaient l'an dernier un chiffre
d'affaires de 50 milliards d'euros au
cernil échappe pas deuxièmement la place
des cordeliers et j'ai été parfaitement
clair c'est la place qui aujourd'hui se
développe le mieux encore de ville c'est
devenu la grande place du rendez-vous
des restaurants des bistrots des bars je
n'ai pas dit que j'allais faire quelque
chose j'ai dit que j'allais lancer la
concertation d'abord et avant tout et si
à l'arrivée nous avons un consensus nous
ferons quelque chose s'il n'y a pas de
consensus eh bien nous ne ferons rien et
c'est pas la place du maréchal leclerc
c'est pas la place à trèbes qui était
aujourd'hui sont des places activer des
places commerçantes il faut arrêter avec
cela un arrêt mon oui nous avons entendu
sociaux sur le sur le problème du
commerce il ya quand même eu aussi une
autre raison nous vivons une époque de
déflation salariale nous savons bien un
problème de pouvoir d'achat donc c'est
pas le maire qui va régler le problème
du pouvoir d'achat on est bien d'accord
mais ça déjà c'est un problème de
politique générale deuxièmement j'ai une
solution quand même russie pour
développer à terme le coeur de ville
c'est que les citoyens puissent se
déplacer plus facilement plus librement
d'éclairer au centre-ville descente du
centre-ville aux clairions lagarde la
proposition ma proposition de gratuité
des transports en commun comme le
pratiquent déjà 20 villes en france
aujourd'hui comme le pratiqueront après
les élections et dans l'est dans l'année
qui suivra des dizaines d'autres vies
c'est la gratuité des transports ou là
on a une liberté de circuler on n'hésite
plus à sortir ont des blessés de plus à
partir parce que justement des problèmes
de pouvoir d'achat aussi donc analysons
bien ce problème de la gratuité de la
possibilité de la gratuité des
transports urbains et je crois qu'on
fera déjà un grand en progrès dans pas
mal de domaines on peut finir sur les
transports oft est du coup je voulais
revenir en un mot sur les constructions
demeure sur les constructions sur un
sujet un petit peu périphériques et à
propos d'une information que vous nous
avez délivré récemment à auxerre qui
concerne l'éventuelle construction d'une
quatrième mosquée je crois que le mot
lieu de culte et un peu plus juste un
contenu mosquée on imagine un droit
bâtiment avait quelque chose de rond
salle de prière 280 places qui est prévu
dans le projet avec seulement six places
de parking donc on imagine aisément les
preuves de circulation dont alors je
voulais revenir sur ce thème i pour que
les choses soient bien claires bien
évidemment la presse locale on a parlé
nous aussi et c'est bien définir les
réponses des uns et des autres puisque
sur ce sujet vous mettiez un petit peu
dans le même sac si j'ose dire ps ump et
c'est d'abord qu'est ce que vous dites à
propos de ce projet ce que vous
confirmez est ce que vous dites toujours
qu'un quatrième lieu de culte va se
construire auxerre écouter début
décembre 2013 a été déposée a permis de
construire en mairie d'auxerre dont ils
ont un numéro provisoire donc c'est bien
que le dossier est enregistrée alors
après il sera accepté hop accepter
monsieur ferraille zadi qui sera pas
acceptée en l'état actuel des choses
donc ils vont sûrement redéposer très
prochainement un dossier en bonne et due
forme donc c'est une mosquée qui fait
280 places c'est la quatrième salle de
prière lieux de culte musulmans auxerre
nous pensons que ça fait beaucoup pour
une ville comme auxerre faut savoir que
la droite et la gauche systématiquement
signe pour les mosquées puisqu'à sens
tous les conseillers municipaux ump ont
voté l'accord d'une mosquée de 5000 m² à
sens nous opposons nous sommes les seuls
et toujours où nous nous sommes opposés
au projet de mosquée voilà ça va être la
clé le quatrième du culte et le danger
c'est le communautarisme c'est à dire
que chaque communauté veulent leur
mosquée place corot nous avons les
communautés ça veut pas forcément dire
mosquée il yad'autres communauté de
communauté à communauté nationale
voilà plus en plus lassés les turcs
demain qui sait qui nous dit qu'il aura
pas les congolais les sénégalais
peut-être les maliens les tadjik et que
sais-je encore mais voilà c'est ça le
communautarisme c'est que chaque
communauté
discours là je ne peux pas l'accepter
sept mots comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur gilbert la montée du
communautarisme et c'est lui moi je vois
ici des auxerrois qui viennent de pays
européens qui viennent de nos régions
fortes averses moi je suis breton au
départ effectivement je devrais être là
d'après ce que j'entends c'est certain
je suis pas né aux serbes qu'est ce que
tu voulais donc ça suffit ça y'a pas de
communautarisme il ya des auxerrois qui
ont des origines du off voilà donc c'est
vraiment vous prononcés pour l'accord à
la mosquée et ben moi je ne suis pas
d'accord
alors ce qui ce que je vois ce que je
vois autour de moi c'est qu'il ya
plupart des colistiers de monsieur
l'arrivée qui applaudissent
effectivement qui sont compétents qui
s'en sont le projet de mosquée donc
monsieur il arrivait très certainement
et avec très certainement d'accord à ce
projet d'émission précise paul a bien
évidemment alors la caisse sur la
question précise éventuellement est ce
l'arrivée vous lirez âge et je vais
répondre très très posément moi je suis
pour le respect de la loi la loi est la
même pour tous quand j'étais en
responsabilité au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai personnellement
coordonner la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical et contre le
djihadisme d'animer une cellule
coordonnant les services de police les
services de renseignement pour expulser
des prédicateurs islamistes radicaux qui
menaçaient la sécurité nationale dont je
sais ce dont je parle
la loi elle doit être respectée et la
liberté de culte elle doit également
être respectés au nom de quoi au nom de
quoi j'interdirais à des travailleurs
turcs ou franco-turc d'exercer leur
culte dans des conditions dignes et pas
dans une cave et pas dans une arrière
boutique moi je suis pour le respect de
la loi pour le respect également des
règles d'urbanisme et je reprends ce que
disait alain rémond un instant en effet
nous sommes tous auxerrois parce que
nous vivons à auxerre parce que nous
faisons le choix de participer à la vie
auxerroises lorsque le candidat
socialiste il y a quelques jours déclaré
sur votre antenne moi je suis un vrai
auxerrois disent-ils quart suit naos
heures moi je suis né à mulhouse parce
que mon père était officier j'ai été
baptisé haus heures aussi j'ai pas le
droit d'être candidat à la mairie
d'auxerre parce que je ne suis pas né
aux soeurs je n'ai pas le droit d'être
député à l'assemblée nationale si je
n'étais pas né en france je pense que
vous savez et chacun jugera il ya
parfois des des proximités
singulière guy ferrier fort de l'émoi
relevé
d'abord je voudrais dire que je fais
bien évidemment les les propos d'alain
rémond et on retrouve là dans la bouche
de monsieur gilbert
raidir les fantasmes traditionnel de la
droite extrême ce que nous avons nous
aussi on veut lancer au service que lui
le destin il n'ya pas distingué entre
les uns et les autres ne peuvent tous un
moment des enfants d'auxerre sur le
poêle partie l'agglo et vale a suggéré
de la communauté saint julien et c'est
répondre aux différents je voudrais
répondre aussi à guillaume larrivé rap
je n'ai jamais oui mais je n'ai jamais
reproché à guillaume larrivé de ne pas
être des à auxerre ce que chez nous
c'est que je lui ai reproché
ces deux un moment vouloir faire croire
qu'il était un enfant d'auxerre et je
vais vous révéler une anecdote on a le
droit de ne pas être d'auxerre et on a
le droit d'être candidats aux serres
souci label mobilités de l'autre pays
mais là raymond voulait masquer à la
raymond guillaume larrivé voulait
masquer le fait qu'il n'était pas aussi
roi nous étions il ya quinze jours
exactement nous participions tous les
deux guillaume larrivé mamère à
l'assemblée générale d'une association
de quartier importante de notre ville et
à la raymond allard et mangeant veut
vraiment pour vous la ignoble arriver
expliqué que ses grands parents
demeurant aux franges de ce quartier
d'une certaine manière il était lui-même
issu du quartier je ne vous reproche pas
de ne pas être auxerrois je vous
reproche de le masquer allez allez vous
rendre à votre avis j'aimerais qu'on
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît sur le public face aux vraies
questions quant à un garde tout le monde
n'est pas venu avec ses militants donc
j'essaie de garder le silence dans le
public mais non mais je soigne un débat
d'une je souhaite un débat d'une grande
dignité le candidat socialiste multiplie
des attaques personnelles de base étages
sans doute est-il fébrile je vais vous
le dire les yeux dans les yeux que je
vous le dis l'arrivée les yeux dans les
yeux sont faits par an ce sont heureux
mariés à l'église des rosoirs cela vous
plaît où cela ne vous plaît pas c'est un
fait voilà c'est ainsi je ne vais pas
m'excuser d'être ce que je suis je ne
vais pas m'excuser d'aller voulu le
cacher je ne vais pas m'excuser d'être
auxerrois y de faiblesse que de lui
aujourd'hui dans les îles où il est
seulement passe à autre chose que j'ai
des questions aussi les blessures
internes et minable monsieur le candidat
des parcs monsieur gilbert préférait
vous êtes inscrit au barreau de paris
pau barreau d'auxerre je vous répondrai
une question durée matrix erreur oui en
effet je considère qu'il est important
que une activité professionnelle soit
maintenue par les élus moi je ne veux
pas vivre des indemnités des autres et
en effet j'ai un métier j'ai un métier
que j'exerce je fais parfois du conseil
juridique même si en ce moment il est
certain que le temps manque sans doute
pour cela mais là encore je ne vais pas
m'excuser moi je veux pas vivre aux
crochets de la collectivité je m'engage
à fond mais je veux aussi maintenir un
pied dans la vie de l'entreprise à une
question sur sur les transports quand
même parce qu on en a on l'a très vite
et l'oubli je vous demanderai des bref
parce qu'on va bientôt arriver à l'heure
du flash j'ai deux questions
d'internautes allez vous continuer les
uns et les autres à densifier le réseau
de bus vivacité et le hameau de laborde
qui demande à être attaché à ce réseau
rapidement les uns et les autres votre
position là dessus très vite alain weill
aucune raison que effectivement en cire
une part d'une même petit des habitants
n'ait pas droit aux bus donc on
reviendra là dessus et le plus
rapidement possible mais je voudrais
effectivement que demain après l'ex et
les élections quel que soit le résultat
de celle ci on puisse réellement
regarder ce dossier de la possibilité de
la gratuité des transports en commun qui
est une solution écologique social qui
permet d'apporter un peu de pouvoir
d'achat par mais c'est l'essentiel
quelquefois la fin du mois pour certains
différends 30 secondes vous êtes un peu
en retard en temps de parole alesi a je
suis en retard donc génère embarquant
cette année encore 30 secondes palois
dans la gratuité des transports c'est
une illusion pourquoi les transports
sont financés aujourd'hui par qui impute
60% par les entreprises
la communauté de cerro apps est une
compétence de la communauté assure une
subvention d'équilibré et l'usager ne
paie qu'à peine 20 % du prix réel du
billet du transport et donc a forcément
quelqu'un qui paye le transport n'est
pas gratuit il y a quelqu'un qui le paye
à l'arrivée j'ai jamais dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de cool transférant jamais on
reprendra dans quelques instants mais là
je vous proposais de faire une courte
pause pour laisser place à quelques
messages et l'info régionale le flash
vous est présenté ce midi par emmanuel
pas sono on se retrouve